- [Narrator] We're told a
rollercoaster has C cars,
each containing 20 seats, and
it completes r rides a day.
Assuming that no one can
ride it more than once a day,
the maximum number of people that can ride
the rollercoaster in a single day is P.
Write an equation that relates P, c and r.
Pause this video and
see if you can do that.
All right, before I even
look at the variables,
I'm just gonna try to think
it out in plain language.
So what we want to think about is
what is the max number of
people per day, people per day,
and so that's going to be equal to
the number of cars in our rollercoaster,
so number of cars,
times the maximum number
of people per car,
times the max number per car.
So this would just tell you
the maximum number of people per ride.
So then we have to multiply,
times the number of rides per day.
So times we do this in a new color,
times number of rides per day.
Now, what are each of these things?
They would have either given us numbers
or variables for each of them.
The max number of people per day,
that's what we're trying to set
on one side of the equation,
that is this variable P, right over here.
So we'll take capital P is equal to
what's the number of cars per coaster?
I guess you could say.
Let me write it this way, per
coaster, per rollercoaster.
So they give us that right over here,
rollercoaster has c cars.
So that's going to be this
variable here in orange
or this part of it, that's c.
Now what's the maximum
number of people per car?
Well, they say each containing 20 seats.
So I'd multiply that
times 20 for this part,
and then I want to multiply that
times the number of rides per day
for the entire rollercoaster.
So that's going to be
times r, and we're done.
We can rearrange this a little bit,
We can write this as P is equal to 20
times cr, and we're done.